pour finir je vous invite à plonger dans
le grand bain avec les membres du club
retraite en forme comme chaque année il
participe ce week-end à l'opération
touraine nage depuis hier soir 18 heures
ils se sont relayés dans les eaux de la
piscine de bréquigny pendant quelques
brasses cet après midi loïc mathieu et
vincent barthe les ont accompagnés il
laisse passer la chandeleur le carnaval
aussi mais n'ont pas la patience
d'attendre le printemps c'est tous les
ans la même chose par un février elle se
met à l'eau à la sainte honorine et n'en
sortent qu'à la saint-romain les rennais
flotte aligne des longues heures pendant
que d'autres les additionne il y en a
qui viennent le matin le midi le soir la
nuit aussi pour atteindre 5000
participants
vous voici raconté touré nage et ça
tombe bien parce que c'est tant pis il
n'empêche parmi les courageux méritants
qui nagent il ya des nageurs courageux
qui mérite plus que les autres ils sont
du club retraite en forme et ils ont la
pêche
l'oeuvre très tentant pour l'instant on
est rendu à trois kilomètres et le marco
avec ses 75 ans dans l'eau quand il va
sortir savez vous ce qu'il va faire et
tac ça vous la coupe 1 va pas lui car il
s'est quand même offert ces trois
kilomètres 500 abris qui me allez salut
et à l'année prochaine dans l'eau au
moulin pour un sujet de fond